so Ryan Sullivan asked me a question on
Twitter and here it is my videos don't
have editing but it was predicated on
this tweet that I put out and my tweet
was to Samsung saying Samsung in a
mobile world unlike web where where the
banners on the right side or print where
I could just change the page or a
commercial where I fast forward them
that's a whole nother video for another
day
TV DVR is killing that industry I mean
2013 I feel like it so 9 but I'm
actually saying that out loud anyway let
me stay focused mobile ads that stop me
from going to where I'm going make me
want to buy that product less so I
tweeted that Samsung say Samsung you
know I'm pissed up less likely I'm
actually never gonna buy anything from
Samsung now based on I wanted to go to
yes we valuable to me
but then tweet came out said well isn't
that ESPN's fault here's where it gets
interesting
ESPN brings me value I like ESPN I want
to go there for a quick score be the
headline and so I'm willing to be
annoyed for a second because it's
bringing me value Samsung is bothering
my experience with an ad and is not
bringing me value obviously if it's
bring me value somewhere else in the
world that's cool but advertising works
to bring in new customers a lot of times
not just reinforce we need to be in a
place this erroneous serious we need to
be in a place where we start debating
the context of the impression not just
the impression I don't give a [ __ ] if
you've got a hundred million impressions
if a hundred million of those mobile
impressions made that customer pissed
off with your brand
you lose okay think about this way high
school the girl you loved and the bully
in your school that you hated you saw
them equally 250 times but you felt
different about each one of them the
context of the impression is something
that needs to start being debated in the
advertising world
it's friggin 2013 can we please debate
the context of the impression I don't
give a crap how many you have I give a
crap how the person feels when they see
it road-blocking Mobile sucks [ __ ]